لذلك تقول Google إنها طورت
نظام ذكاء اصطناعي يمكنه
اكتشاف سرطان الثدي بشكل أكثر دقة
من الأطباء ، وقد تم تطوير البرنامج
باستخدام عشرات الآلاف من صور الثدي بالأشعة السينية
من النساء في الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة ،
ووجد تقرير أنه يقلل من الإيجابيات
الكاذبة والسلبيات الكاذبة.
Shetty هو مدير المنتج والقائد
التقني في Google health ،
وينضمون إلي الآن من سان فرانسيسكو ، إنه لمن الرائع
أن تشارك في العرض عام جديد سعيد
وتهنئتك على النتائج التي توصلت إليها
وتطوير هذه التكنولوجيا الجديدة ، شكرًا
لك عامًا جديدًا سعيدًا ، لذلك من
الرائع رؤيتك  كيف أن اكتشاف السرطان باستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي أفضل بكثير من الأطباء وأنت
تستخدم معلومات أقل للقيام بذلك ، كيف
يعمل ذلك ، لذلك على مستوى عالٍ ،
استخدمنا مبدأين أحدهما مشابه
لما قد يفعله أطباء الأشعة في
الممارسة العملية ، وهما  انظر إلى صور
الثدي الشعاعية هذه وابحث عن آفات صغيرة
عليها ثم نجمع كل هذه
المعلومات ثم نتوقع
مخاطر الإصابة بسرطان الثدي  المبدأ الآخر الذي
استخدمناه هو النظر إلى الصور على مستوى العالم
والتي تنظر في جميع السياقات
والصور ثم نتنبأ بسرطان
الثدي ونجمع بين الاثنين للتنبؤ
بالمخاطر النهائية وهناك العديد من الطرق
لدمج هذا في سير عمل
يمكن أن يكون  على جانب الأجهزة ولكن يمكن أن
تكون أيضًا على جانب البرنامج ، لذا
لا يتطلب بالضرورة
تعديلًا تحديثيًا في الأجهزة الحالية ، لذا فهذه نتائج مثيرة للاهتمام Travie
ولكنك تعرف ما الذي يتطلبه الأمر لإدخاله
فعليًا في النظام الذي
نتحدث عنه  بعد سنوات من الآن ، هل
ننظر إليك وأنتم تعلمون أنكم تفكرون في
التعاون مع شركات مختلفة ،
كيف تخططون للقيام بذلك بالفعل ، أعتقد أن
الكثير من هذه الخيارات مطروحة على الطاولة
ويعتمد الكثير منها على معرفتك
بالتطبيق المعين  التي
نبنيها ولكننا حريصون على العمل مع
مجموعات تنظيمية لمزودي المرضى
مثل إدارة الغذاء والدواء أو مجموعات الأقراص المدمجة في أوروبا
لفهم أفضل لكيفية رغبتهم في تنفيذ
هذه التجارب  حتى يتمكنوا من
التوصية أو عدم
استبدال الموصلات ، فهل سيتم
استبدالهم ، لذا فقد أشرت
قليلاً في وقت سابق لا نعتقد
أنه واحد مقابل الآخر في الواقع ما
رأيناه في نتائجنا
هناك عدد من الحالات حيث  يعمل الذكاء
الاصطناعي بشكل صحيح والأطباء لا يفعلون ذلك ، ولكن
هناك أيضًا عددًا من الحالات التي يصحح فيها
الأطباء والذكاء الاصطناعي لا
أعتقد أنهم يستطيعون أن يكملوا بعضهم البعض وأن
الجمع بين الاثنين هو ما يمكن أن
يساعد في إبراز نقاط القوة في  كل